good morning London
hello world welcome to Let's code an
incremental generator with wrestling
I am Stefan pertz I love clean code I
love test driven development so we will
be seeing a lot of tests today I am a
senior developer at trayport at the
office in Vienna but they had
headquarters here in London that I
visited also this week
I since a couple of months I'm a
Microsoft MVP which was very exciting
and also for a couple of months I am a
chat brains Community contributor which
potentially will become
positive for you at the end so stick
around also I'm a co-organizer of the
cognitive 80 Meetup in Vienna we're
doing User Group meetups in Vienna
about.net
since last year I also stream at twitch
and of YouTube under the handle
flashover
and on Twitter I am Cox underscore F0 if
you have potentially some questions
later on that I can't answer later on at
the Q a section
um all the slides are online the example
that we're building live not yet it will
be you can get the Via flashover.net NDC
London but I'll be showing this at the
end again if you want to check check
that out
so what is rustling
um Boston is the.net compiler platform
for the languages c-sharp and Visual
Basic and it also allows extensibility
model so that I as a consumer of.net as
a developer can write plugins basically
for that I can write analyzers which
show bubblies
curlies or you get a you get the
warnings or errors in your IDE you can
also provide a code fixer which then
offers a controlled Auto Art enter
experience depending on the IDE you are
using in order to fix that problem so it
offers suggestions you can also do a
refactoring provider which is basically
a code fix without a diagnostic so that
doesn't necessarily have to be a warning
for example if you change from file from
block scope namespace to file scope
namespaces
and you can also do a diagnostic
suppressor which is suppressing warnings
though
and since dotnet 5 we can also write
Source generators there's two interfaces
we will have a look at the letter
because that has been added in.net 6 and
offers a performance in potential
performance Improvement to the first
iteration now I'm wondering who is
consciously consuming some Western
components such as an analyzer in their
projects
I see like roughly half the room who of
you has actively already built something
with Foster for example an analyzer or a
source generator
10 15 okay cool I hope I got for those
who already have experience with it also
something new in store today
so when it comes to Source generation
there has been through the history
of c-sharp's particular
features in edit for example the partial
type uh the partial keyword and I want
to specifically point out to the c-sharp
9 version of that
because in C sharp nine previously we
could only make if we if we would make a
type and a method partial it cannot have
an accessibility modifier so it's
inherently
um uh for private and it cannot have a
return type which means if there is no
partial doesn't have an implementation
and if at compilation there is no
implementation nobody's providing it not
the developer not not some other tool
then this call to this partial method is
actually is
um is removed so this is why it cannot
have any return
return types or out parameters and this
restriction has been lifted in C sharp 9
by explicitly adding an accessibility
modifier so if you're specific to a
partial method explicitly say this is
public this is internal not a new rules
applied and the new world say okay we
can have return types and out parameters
and such but we must have an
implementation if there is no
implementation at compile time either
via manual white or a for example Source
generator then this will be a compiler
error
and we will have we will use the partial
keyword will be the center of our
example today
speaking of generators so they have been
editing.net 5 and in.net6 or since.net6
the Nets team is also actively using
them so we will get Source generators in
the PCL for example in.net 6 system text
Json generator and a logging generator
and I'm going to show you the benefit of
using that login generator
so I have here A Benchmark with
benchmark.net
and a logger
and here I basically set the minimum log
level so it has to be at least
information or warning and I want the
tests with both ldfd log level is lower
then no log will be emitted
and I try to log with different
variations for example the classic
extension method via log information
another version is
to actually guard that log information
level with a check if this log level
actually has been enabled
and the third variant this is the source
generated version
let's have a look at the performance
output
so we see if the okay yeah so we log
information and we if we actually do set
the minimum level as information so it
actually gets locked then we see that
the extension method does allocate for
the six bytes of memory
and also if it's if guarded because the
if God will be true so it's basically
the same path
and without that now
without that if God if the log level is
higher for example warning so we are now
the minimum Block Level is warning we
log in information so that doesn't get
locked
if we do not have that if check
B also allocate 64 bytes of memory
but if you do have that if check we
don't why is that
there are some hidden allocations in
this extension method so if we have a
look at the implementation
we will see that takes a paragram's
object away
and for the c-sharp compiler emits for
this is actually an in a way
instantiation we don't see this in the
code but the compiler will emit this so
for every invocation we will initialize
in Array of size 2 and also we have a
number here
number is a structure type a value type
and if we cast the two object we will
have boxing and this these are
additional allocations on the hip
so we always make sure to guard
those invocations because we spare those
object away allocations if we do not log
and the source generated version
is here I have here a partial class so
that the source generator can actually
add something at compile time to it
then have the partial method
which takes a logger and those two
arguments the name and the number that I
have in this string format
and for the Swatch terminal generates we
can have a look at this we see now in
wider is a very similar experience in
Visual Studio the file here is has a bit
of a yellow tint this means it's it's
generated if I try to edit this
pop-up will appear and says hey this is
a source generated file this is actually
not physically on disk so you have to
save this first in order to edit it
and the source generator what it does is
actually
generate this if this log level has been
enabled check for us so we can in this
case the source generator
saves us performance and also
avoid this tedious implementation so our
source code is actually cleaner because
we don't have those manual if checks all
over the place and this is a very strong
benefit of source generators and I also
want to show an example from
seven
which is a wedgex generator so with red
checks there is always a bit of
performance consideration if you always
knew up a new web checks that's rather
expensive every new HX to invoke the
first time is very expensive you can set
the compiled flag which means that only
the first is match implication is
expensive and saves that saves that call
them to the assembly and reuses that but
still that first call is expensive and
we also generate code at one time and if
the source generator
all that code is generated at compile
time so we move there's a lot of code so
we move that complexity from one time to
compile time and oh and the first
invocation is as fast as any other
because this is cached and we don't have
to write all of this ourselves to get
high performance regex
so those are those two main use cases
for Source generators they save tedious
implementation and can also boost your
performance
now what are the laws of source
generation the input of a source
generation is actually the code that the
user has written in this very project so
the entire seat this all the C sharp
files or the Visual Basic files in this
in this compilation so in the Cs project
are an input to the source generator The
Source generator gets this as the
so-called syntax tree
what's a syntax tree
we can check that out via the site a
sharp clip
dot IO
and let's have a look at the standard
code here if we appear switch oops
up here switch from C sharp to the
syntax tree now this is the wrestling
representation of this source code so we
are in a compilation unit and there is
and we see this is this tree structure
now we have we have a using directive
and we have a class declaration
and this class declaration has for
example the public keyword
the class keyword it has an identifier
so that we can use it in this case
um it's a c
and it can also have members for example
a method declaration which again has the
return type is a predefined type in this
case White and the identifier is m
and this is syntactic
this is to the rules of C sharp
syntactic and we can also get meaning
for that code so if I write for example
I want to return an INT 32.
now it says in 32 and I assume it's
system in 32 but I could technically
have my own
implementation of system int32 well this
would cause a ambiguity but I could have
there's the same type name which is
actually totally different
and but as I meant syntactically it
looks like an INT but semantically it
doesn't necessarily have to be so the
semantics is actually then having a look
at this type what is it what members
does it have
and this is then the
second input that we can get from the
within the source generator
so we can ask the semantic models
questions about the meaning of our code
we can add the source generators can add
many sources or no sources at all
and we add them as a string so the
output of a source generator is a string
that then gets fed into the compilation
and then together with the already
existing user code is compiled again and
this is where the partial thing kicks in
so we have the user codes partial the
sourceometer is partial then they get
compiled into one type into one
implementation of this method
social media is additive only we cannot
remove we cannot alter code we cannot
rename anything so we cannot we can only
currently add new code to it
since a source generator is technically
an analyzer we could also produce
diagnostics for example warnings now
there is of course a
performance consideration with that but
we'll come together a little bit later
um oblivious that means if I have
multiple Source generators in one
project all of them get the very same
input The Source generator currently
this may change in the future a source
generator cannot depend on the output of
another generator all of them get the
same input of this one project
and yeah I mentioned the use cases the
typical use cases already
um so tooling that I like to use for
example is shoplab where you can have a
look at the syntax tree a visual studio
has a has a similar uh with
representation
um with via the visual studio syntax
analyzer and there's also the waslam
quota that I want to have a brief look
at
this is basically the other way around
so I can put the empty sharp code let's
create a class
and then I see what was link code I
would need to write in order to get that
and this would look
let's enable the syntax Factory
so via the syntax Factory we can create
compilations
and well this is somewhat helpful so to
social videos perhaps to understand the
structure this is very very useful for
analysis and other models
what did you call that website uh the
Western quarter but all of this is on
GitHub so you can have a look at the
links later on
uh when it comes to versioning since
there is many many versions of
of wrestling I created a little bit of a
matrix
if I find it there it is
so
we start with Western freepoint
eight this is the Wilson version that is
included in the.net 5 SDK which means if
my source trivet is targeted in mostly
in 3.8 the consumer must at least have
the.net 5 SDK so the first
um
I was like the gold release version one
after the release candidate has been has
been released if I want to use
additional features for example in 3.9
post initialization has been added we
will have a look at it what this means
and if I if my social is targeting 3.9
the consumer must have the dotnet SDK
5.0.200 so depending on the western
version I Target
the consumer of the generator which then
invokes it and produces code needs to
have respectively a higher version of
the.net SDK
and I also list the compatibility
versions with wider if you want to have
a look at this later on
what we will be using since we will be
using post initialization
we will also be using the incremental
generator because they offer potentially
performance boost over the classic
isosce generators
uh we'll we will not be using with
tracking name this isn't directly
helpful for the generator plus C but if
you have tooling that runs the generator
you can produce some more Diagnostics
with that
there was also a error a bug in the
previous version which is fixed in 4.2
and in 4.3 which is the last release of
the within the.net 6 SDK time frame a
new
method has been introduced in order to
analyze where
the user is using specific attributes
and we're gonna make heavy use of that
so now let's jump to the live coding
example
the example that I would like to build
um how I started here is actually I
built a
template for Source generators
and basically what I did uh
in the morning
is
invoking this command
via.net new
this template is available on nougat if
you want to have a look at it it's it
contains the search generator it
contains tests it also contains
benchmarks and you can then water easily
there's not much more you have to do in
order to publish the investors generator
as a nougat package if you find that
helpful as a Kickstart
which is this project
fco.templates also available in nougat
but yeah the link is in the in the
slides if you want to check that out
later
so let's jump to the example that I
would like to build
so as most of the times when it comes to
Source generators I start with a
benchmark
so what I had a look at is the enum is
defined
so enum is defined basically checks we
have an enum in our case here the
logging enum again
and we can check if that value
if we when we pass in a value if this is
part of the inner there is a constant
defined with that value
because if you check out the log level
um
enum which is part of
microsoft.extensions.logging.abstractions
package we see they have values provided
and we can since the underlying type of
an enorm default is an integer we can
assign any integer to that enum
so let's have a look at e
test actually first
for example a field a test I start with
negative one
and the value 0 through 6 are actually
defined in the enum but 7 again is not
so is defined short return false
and this test confirms that it works
okay I feel I give it away the generated
version but for the for the PCL version
enum. is defined
this is how it works in dotnet framework
the generic version doesn't exist yet so
we need to use the type of overload
and everyone that benchmarks I don't
know so I
um and since inundo is defined is using
reflection under the hood there is a bit
of a performance
hit
and
what if we theoretically we had a
generated version which is a little bit
more naive but um does it more direct
without reflection what what's the
performance difference be
and in our case
so actually so this was the test sorry
let's have a look at the benchmark
so The Benchmark we won the ecl version
we won a hand-walled version this is
then the E version I meant so we
basically have just a value at the check
is a choice is it debug or any of those
seven values from 0 to 6 and if it's not
if it's negative one or any other
integer then it will return false
and a performance difference between
these
is measure global so the BCL version has
15 nanoseconds and the hand-world
version is
fairly measurable because it's rather
naive it's just checking some some
integers and so this handled version the
downside is this handled version only
works for log level
so this only works for log level I
cannot use it for any other Eno
uh where is defined I could use for any
other email so again it would be very
tedious to implement this hand-world
version for every enum again and if that
even changes if somebody adds a value
then basically the handwalled version
could be invalid so wouldn't it be cool
if we had a generator automatically
doing this tedious work for us and this
is what we will build now
before we really start let's have a look
at the Cs project
because it's important that the source
generator is targeting.net standard 2.0
this is because there is various tools
out there there is Visual Studio which
still works on.net framework Wireless
backend sweating on.net core or dot net
so we still need to target.net standard
2.0 in order to have in order to make
this generator consumable from any from
any tooling
um I do multi-targeting with the latest
Target framework in order to get
nullable reference type annotations so
there's a little bit of a trick this is
then not part of the nougat package
because if we have a look then later on
we will only pack the.net standard 2.0
version there is a trick this is
Microsoft actually does multi-targeting
with different Western versions but I
couldn't figure this out yet
um
So currently we target one version and
it must be extended 2.0
and here I suppress the null ability
warnings for net standard because.net
standard 2.0 was c-sharp 7.3 and they
have there are no nullable annotations
yet which have been added in C sharp 8
and have been introduced with the.net
core free SDK and more and more
annotations have been added so the
questions marks and various attributes
for for reference types and I ignore
them for Open Standards but for the.net
7 build I use them in order to get the
warnings to get the null ability right
so let's have a look at the interface
the eye incremental generator interface
so our generator has to implement this
interface and there is only one method
the initialize method and from that we
build a pipeline
and this pipelining approach is the huge
difference between the net 5 isource
generators
and with this pipeline approach we will
see that at the end we can shortcut we
can short circuit separate steps in
order to avoid duplicate work if it has
if it has already been
um the same as the previous one we will
see the benefit at the end
so
when we start
we
implement the initialize method and I
mentioned it before there was post
initialization
and post initialization actually enables
a bit of ordering so we can actually
code that we
produce in the post initialization phase
of the generator can actually be used in
subsequent generator phases in the in
the in the general output phase in our
case so this is how actually we can
generate source which we later on depend
on
and in this example
I am putting out an attribute
the is enum defined attribute this is
all this is actually a c-sharp 11
attribute we see this is a generic
attribute
which also takes a type and this type
must be an enum
so it must be a struct which derives
from you know we can't manually derive
from the enum type because drugs cannot
derive any other classes but
um
internet.net so the PCL the.net team
knows how to do that it's part I'm
actually not sure but
um so this is a check
um to know this is an enum yeah
and I want to apply this email to a
class
and then on this class on this partial
class I want to emit those is defined
methods so I'm marking a class
for the generator to observe and create
the relevant implementations of the is
defined there
it's always good practice to add the
auto generated comment at an auto
generated file so that's tooling knows
oh this is also generated for example an
analyzer and analyzer there's a flag if
you also want to analyze
auto-generated file the default you
should rather not because the user has
no direct influence on this generator on
the generated file and if this will
produce warnings and if the if the
developer had warning this errors this
would be very annoying cannot actually
fix that it would need to fix but they
would need to fix the generator if they
don't have Source access that's
troublesome
and also I like nullability so I always
enable nullability because in generated
files the default nullability context is
false there are no nullable limitations
then it's another good practice to add
the generated code attribute
we find it up here
generated code attribute adds the name
of this assembly and also
the version again this is for tooling
this is for not source code base tooling
because the comment may not be emitted
in the in the in the metadata of the
assembly but for example reflection
based tooling would be able to read this
attribute and know okay this is a
generated file I may should tweet this
differently
and we're putting it is in the western
dot generated namespace
and now this is actually
what we have so if we want
the tests
while having a look at them
I am here again defining this attribute
that I'm checking against we see this is
all strings because that's the output of
a generator and I have here test if I
don't have any candidate candidates so
this this partial class does not have
this new attribute applied then nothing
should be generated except this one
is a non-defined attribute this is not
necessarily the best practice to emit
those marker attributes also via Source
generator because if we have multiple
assemblies using the generator now we
have this type it's an internal type but
still we have this now multiple
assemblies so you could also
produce this marker type this attribute
in a separate assembly intercept with
nougat package that then the generator
is also automatically including and the
only way of this type once
but for our case this shows how the post
initialization phase works because we
are first outputting this
attribute and then later on we can
search it
and this is not a second test you see
this is not failing because in the
second test we actually want to use that
is you know defined attribute so we can
now depend on it and if we find that now
I want to Output the code so this is now
what should be generated the partial
class again
and now there is defined method
with in our case we're using string
comparison because this is what we
defined up here
and now emit all the enots for that
doing the logic all the enum constants
and then doing basically string
comparison and check has this really
been created I do have here a bit of a
name it's the is
enumgenerated.g.cs so if you have a
generated file always add dot g dot CS
or dot generated CS again the tooling
nodes or the reader knows okay this is
generated
but this is not necessarily a file per
default those Source generated sources
are not put to disk there is an
um in this build flag that you can set
and also a directory that you can put to
actually see on disk what gets emitted
for debugging purposes perhaps but by
default this is just the hint name for
tooling to show but it's not necessarily
put to disk it's not necessarily A
source file
now our test is failing
let's have a look why
uh yeah because I implemented it correct
and
so let's get to it
since we want to search for
this enote type
let's have a closer look how this looks
in the syntax tree
so if we
go to the test
if we grab
that example
go to sharflip.io put us in
now it doesn't compile but we can still
have a look at the syntax tree
we are searching
for class declaration that have in the
attribute list
this very attribute
and in previous version it was what a
manual in order to search for that you
really have to drill down have a look at
all the class declaration see if they're
attribute lists contain this very
attribute and basically a two for each
Loops in order search for it and the
Western 3. 4.0 4.3 sorry a very nice
feature has been added that does that
for us and I guess also the most
performant way because the Western team
they know what they do so we can write
on the syntax provider
we can write dot for attribute with
metadata name
and now we provide the metadata name
I have the
is enum defined attribute metadata
which looks like this
perhaps you have seen this in a reflect
in reflection already when we have a
generic type there is this backtick one
which indicates this type has one
generic argument
if it is a pactic 2 it has two and this
is why we can't overload by generic
differences so we can't have an overload
with one generic type parameter with
different types because in metadata they
look the same so we have an ambiguity
now we're searching for these
and then on the
on this provider
we have two more callbacks
we have a predicate we see the input for
that predicate is a syntax node so we
get in each and every syntax node where
this attribute applies to various
metadata attribute has been found on
so we can do further checking and then
we have the transform method and this
transform method now is semantic
because in this generator attribute
context
we not only get the syntax node because
the syntax node that's the name says
it's syntactic we know what it looks
like but we don't know exactly what it
is
but we also get this target symbol in
this case where the attribute has been
applied on in our case the class this is
the symbol is semantic it has Type
information
and
we also get the semantic model so we
could ask additional questions about the
meaning of the code
and we have a collection of attribute
data so we could apply this attribute
multiple times in order to make multiple
methods and PC that's an immutable array
in Gosling almost everything if not
everything is immutable so if we have a
syntax tree and if we edit the syntax
tree this will be entire new syntax tree
I think this is how you enable basically
control C experiences that you can back
go back to previous steps
and this is how a multiplayer is used
you cannot immutably waste obstruct
which has an array under the hood but
you cannot modify that array
and now we will use the predicate the
syntactic jack
we get in a syntax node oops
so let's go let's say node we also have
a cancellation token
and
let's see if this is really really a
class well on the attribute we declared
that this attribute can only be applied
to classes but still let's make sure
that this node is a class so predicate
must return a Boolean so we return if
this node is a class declaration syntax
again how do I know how this is a class
declaration syntax because in sharp lab
if we have a look at the syntax tree we
see
that this class is a class declaration
that's the type that we can check for
and what I also want to check
is that this class indeed is partial
because if the class isn't partial we
cannot add source to this type so we
need to make sure that this is partial
so we can say class
Dot
oh I should add a end
if I make some errors I have my rubber
duck debug here to help me but if you if
you spot any obvious titles please let
me know
and we can
um go for the for the modifiers
and ask the modifiers if
sorry I have to cheat
um because that's the oh yeah right we
use any actually only um
there's an extension method yeah so we
can ask if the kind
if the
partial
keyword is a part of these modifiers so
the modifiers includes the the pub for
example public on the strike to read
only would be a modifier or a partial in
this case and we see if any of these
modifiers is partial and only if this
predicate returns true
then we go into the
syntax
semantic check the transform
not a transform
we see oops that must be a comma sorry
the transform receives a context
again a cancellation token yeah
[Music]
wait thank you
and
here we can again Ask additional
questions I grabbed that from an example
and walk you through
so
since we checked here
that this is a class declaration we can
cast this into the class declaration
syntax denote if it would cost it to
anything else it would crash and then
Source generate a question no sources
are output
so always make sure that it's safe in
general just because it's not when a
source generator creates an error it's
not super super obvious it just doesn't
work and it's then especially if it's a
new good package we are hard to to to to
debug so always make sure that casting
is actually safe
and the so we know that the syntactic
information is a class declaration and
with that we know that the semantic type
is a named type symbol
now we can safely assert that our
attribute list list has at least one
member in it because this is what the
four attributes of metadata name is
doing it ensures that this metadata
named attribute is actually applied at
least once on this syntax node
and then we return this in a tuple
and from that we now go on now we build
up the pipeline
so how does this pipeline work let's
have a look again at the syntax provider
a syntax provider
and the form effort returns an
incremental value provider there is two
of these there is the incremental values
provider plural and there is the
incremental value provider singular an
incremental value provider has one thing
the values provider multiple or zero to
many so that's then later on in a
mutable array
and we have
more of these if you have a look at the
context that we get in to the initialize
method
there is many of these value providers
so we have for example a compilation
provider we can have a look have a
closer look at the compilation there's
only one compilation so this is a value
provider
we can also have a look at the options
of the compilation we can have a look at
the pause options the pass options for
example would include with with which
c-sharp version this project has been
compiled so you could technically
depending on the language version of the
user of the project emits different
codes to be more compatible
thank you
there is also additional texts
additional text is anything that is not
C sharp so I could have a text file an
XML file a Json file that I transform
transpile into a c-sharp source code
not every additional files like a Json
if we have a web project there is the
app settings.json this is not per
default getting in you have to
explicitly Mark in the uh in the MS in
the Cs project
marketed file is an additional file and
all additional files then will be
visible to generators analyzers to all
the hosting tooling
and there is also the metadata reference
provider that I mentioned that had a bug
the bug was that before version 4.2 this
was a value provider not a values
provider and the metadata references for
example are the yeah the assemblies that
this project is depending on for example
uh
Newtons of Json
or other nugget packages
and we can also not only have those
basic providers we can also chain
providers with
link like methods for example because
what we have here now is we have the
class declaration but we have multiple
attributes
now what I want to do because there is
one test
which actually
I thought I had this test but we could
actually apply the same attributes twice
on a type and then we need to emit two
methods
and for that we need to now group these
so I'm doing here a select many
foreign
out those multiple attributes this
attribute data that we have and combine
this with the type information and the
um with the with the syntactic and the
semantic information of this type that
this attribute has been applied on
so this is how we do a select any we
create an array with all this data and
then return the stator so we now switch
from a
from
on single output to multiple outputs
now
we will do a step that will come in
handy later we will now select those
elements that that we need in order to
generate the source code
so we will
drill down and get all the information
what do we need in order to emit this
code
let's have a look so we need the
namespace that this type is in
we need the type name
that this attribute has been applied on
so because we need to mark it as partial
in our edit source
we need to know the enum so not only the
the name of the enum but also the
semantic information of this enum so we
need to know that this enum has those
six constants the current culture
invarian culture and so on so that we
can then emit the source code and we
will grab all this information
so we ask the symbol to get the
containing namespace
and see if this is the global namespace
because if it's if it's in the global
namespace it's also a test for that
so we could we could declare a type
which isn't in a namespace and then we
can't emit any namespace if we try to
get the namespace name of the global
namespace it would be Global namespace
in Brackets and this would be invalidity
sharp code so we need to check for that
we also then get
the name
of this namespace we get the name of the
type
we get the name of the Eno and I'm using
here a format the global Elias format in
order to produce produce this
so it's good practice and instruction
related code to always use the global
alliers in order to avoid potential
ambiguity so the user could declare
their own system.string comparison or
could declare their own in a different
namespace type from the from the BCL and
with that we can potentially avoid this
errors
so it's really
I saw rarely that there was actually
using declaration in in Swatch generated
code
so we need the full name with the global
identify the Global Alliance
and
sorry
and also now we need to get the members
of this enum
we do that by
yeah getting the members
and we need to filter
for all members which are a field
because by default this is what this is
how I learned
while building social service is how I
learn a lot about c-sharp because in
enum actually has a default Constructor
so if I would go
video test
for example the log level I can write
via level equals new log level
so there is a default Constructor for
Enos now be aware that if there is no
zero element in
in that in that enum for example if I
start at one
invoking the default Constructor would
still assign the value 0 to it because
the underlying type is an integer and
the default of the integer is zero so
this is how we could if we don't have a
zero value the default of an enum
already would not be defined
and in order to get width in our
selection of this default Constructor
we will filter
only for the fields
then we convert this to the string again
we say two display string which allows
passing these Elias where we say we can
have a brief look at this this is
basically combining various enums in
order to say okay
uh use special types so if it's actually
saying the language keyword Inked keep
it as Inked
and we include the containing type
and also is the global
uh the global is part of this fully
qualified format already
and now we have all the variables that
we need
now we can
put create
the source
but I still have a compiler ever
um so what do we have
excuse me
twice
ah wait so let's make this this is why I
usually actually also
always Mark themes static in order to
avoid this errors thank you very much
and
I guess I also have a bracing error yes
okay and now we created this pipeline so
we have
selected and
filtered
and now have this one provider
which has now if we have a look at the
type information
this is now an incremental value use
provider of this is enum defined info so
we have multiple of these now we can get
to generation
and we also do it with a context so we
can say context dot actually have it
down here already
register Source output if we want to
produce Diagnostics we could also do to
be a context dot report oh no it's not
it's
down there sorry I confused
um
yes
so now we're with Chester and output
that acts on this pipeline that we have
built
so let me bring that in
uh oops what I forgot is to also collect
because we now have a
we now have an incremental value use
provider
and if I want to change an incremental
values provider which is multiple into a
singular we can say dot collect I'm
doing this in order to be able to put
all because this example you want to put
all the source into one generated file
and so I collect this into one now we
have an immutable array and now
um we can put this into one single file
and now let's bring in the source code
which actually generates the source code
so I will walk you through so we will
get as an input
a source production context via which we
can actually add sources and we get the
result from our pipeline that we built
in our case since we could since we have
since we have collected we get an
immutable array of this type if we
wouldn't have collected we would get
just the easy undefined info singular
but then it would be invoked multiple
times so we could produce multiple files
multiple sources but I want to merge it
into one so this is how I collect
then since we are creating a source I
start here with a string Builder I
wrapped this in an indented text writer
this is how you can do easily invention
always add good practice always add Auto
generated header and notability
information
and now we iterate through all the infos
that we have
we check are we not in the global
namespace then we can print namespace
information
if we are in a global namespace we don't
see anything about the namespace that is
by default in the global
we
print the partial class
now within that partial class this is
here we do indent in order to get nice
a nice invention this helps having a
look at the code later on
then we emit the is defined method with
the name of this item which is the
global column column
version
then this enum could be empty so we
could have an enum without any constants
then we just return false because no
value is defined
there are any constants then we start
emitting this return statement so we
return value is
and then for each constant
we write the constant and or combine it
and if it's the last we just write the
semicolon
and then we close our brackets
so we close to the brace close another
brace then at the end we again need to
check are we in the global namespace
because if we are we all we open the
brace we need to close it now
and then
we build a big string and put this to
this to this and this is where the
actual
emission is happening this is where the
source code is added to
um to the to the next step of the
compilation
we give it we see we give it a hint name
and the hint name now will come in handy
because tooling will show us where it is
so if we build that
and have a look at the example
hope that everything turns
not red
and we can have a look in Rider this is
very similar in Visual Studio
if it will down to the framework that we
are compiling with
there is a source generators folder
here is our source generator and there
are now there we can have a look at
those generated files and these name not
files but sources these are the names
that I use the hint name is used for
that
so we can have a look at the attribute
there it is it's valency sharp code and
we can have a look at this enum that we
Define and here we have it we have
successfully emitted
um the headers we have big since we've
been enough we we are not in the global
namespace we have a namespace we have
the partial class we have the log level
and so on and so forth and now
we can actually run this example and we
are searching if
uh log level.trace is defined
the output is true
and if we would try to say negative 10
cast this into log level
wondering what I'm doing wrong maybe
let's put this into arrival
level
uh what am I doing wrong
instead of bar
excuse me looks like bars giving you an
INT per level yeah
I'm not sure do you know why
uh
oops
your name is not fair at this point
did I forget total cost
I did forget oh is it is it the negative
okay I did
ah okay I did forget how to cast okay
and if we want that we now get we should
get a false
and there we have it and this is now the
faster version so this is now if we have
a look at the full full benchmarks again
this is now the generated version which
is equal to the handheld version because
the very same code has been emitted this
naive check of just checking if any of
these values is the value that we got in
any of these integers in that case
and but we didn't have to um
actually write it so if we now if this
enum would change the source generator
would actually would actually update now
speaking about updating there is still
one thing to left because currently
we're not really use the incrementality
of this generator we just built the
pipeline but we're not using its benefit
just yet and I want to show this by
going back to the generator
and at the top of the uh not file its
source let's write
a comment
that prints the current date time
if we build that
and have a look
at the example at the output
put these next to each other
use the program now we have 11 14. time
is running out if I hit
if I hit return just somewhere now the
source is generated The Source has been
generated a new 15.40 but nothing really
has changed nothing relevant has changed
we didn't add the enum hasn't changed
the the type we didn't add another
attribute we didn't remove an attributes
nothing relevant has changed so we
create the same output again and this is
now what the incremental Source
generator's power is for
and this is by comparing so I'll be
adding now
a comparer
in within the pipeline
so let's jump to the pipeline
before we collect
we have here an
comparer which Compares all of these
elements and for the array does a
sequence equal because the default this
is actually what the default equality
does equal just all the members but then
array isn't the default sequence equaled
so this is how we need to do it manually
and if we rebuild that
now we actually have the incrementality
in place so if we
understand that after the compiler the
output of the of this
um generation phase was the same as the
previous one before we hit enter Then it
basically stops and reuses the
previously emitted output whatever has
been cached and we don't we don't go
into this method again
and the evidence is here so if we have a
look at the generated file
on the right hand side
and if I now hit enter
the 11 16 28 should not update
and it doesn't
but if I add another attribute if I
actually change something relevant which
is mentioned in the pipeline and
mentioned in the in the comparer let's
add a string
comparison in comparison enum here and
I'm not even building it this tooling
now automatically regenerates it we have
a new time and we now also have
the string comparison is defined emitted
but again if I remove some code which is
not relevant to the to the pipeline it
will not update and this is the true
power of the incremental generator and
the pipeline that we built so we need to
build our pipelines efficiently so that
caching can be used
and this concludes the example
um here's a list of the best practices
we went through all of them
and yeah if we want to get started all
the links are online I also put some
more examples for example the community
toolkits this is recently this is
recently and continuously updated with
Source generator improvements recently
with a lot of performance improvements
for example they moved the diagnostics
from the generator to a specific to
analyzer in order to make the generator
faster
um I also have additional references and
videos if you if you want to know more
about generators and
now there is two minutes left for
questions
um what I mentioned the beginning I for
the first two questions I got one
Wireless license for you to score that I
was given by checkpoints
um your type is a record time right in
that case I used to record type it yeah
so it should be good comparable
properties by uh technically technically
yes but we have an array
the array array equals array does not do
a sequence equal
and it's a it's a value type so it's
barely ever equal
you wouldn't need that compare if say
if you didn't have a collection yeah it
was just a normal
record yes yes because the default the
default comparative is used is
um I uh
is it comparative default
um if that exists uh yeah so there is a
default comparing place which just does
just does the I quotable dot equals
invocation or the object overload if I
equals is implemented and that's the
default if we have something special to
do in our case the array we need to
write a custom
copier
I think what was next I actually have
the same question about it okay then
uh
I was using wider because it both have
the advantages both have the
disadvantages I'm using wider because
you can actually build it again and then
I don't need to restart wider and the
new source Trader is picked up the
feature studio if you change the source
generator because it's loaded at startup
time of Visual Studio you need to
restart with your studio if you change
the source generator
um so this is for the for the actual
integration part there's also unit tests
for the unit tests you don't need them
because the idea they would send trust
energy generator is loaded in memory and
I also link it in the slides so the unit
test framework that I'm using is also
for Microsoft which is um
microsoft.code analysis everything was
Lane starts with microsoft.com code
analysis C sharp software does testing
and for that you don't need to restart
Visual Studio but for the actual
deployed version for the if you have the
source generator in code then you need
to restart it
um the advantage of visual studio is
debugging there is a feature that you
can actually have F5 debugging of a
generator you can't do this in in wider
but since with unit tests you can debug
via unit tests so if we jump
to any test let's have a
breakpoint anywhere
go to the unit tests
and
debug it then we will land there
um
but if you have loaded it as a component
as a nougat package then you can't debug
it so those are the two biggest
differences that I saw but everything
else is similar you can develop all of
them both of them offer the you you can
drill down in so we yeah we did hit the
breakpoint
um this view here
is also available in visual studio and
um yeah other than that they're quite
comparable
yes
but one tiny question so when you use a
generated code one of the annoyances is
if you want to go go to declaration and
it's being done by a software generator
then very often it's
found do you have anything for that this
works in both Visual Studio both with
your students why they are aware of that
so if I F12 that is defined I hit I
could hit F12 and I select because I do
multi-targeting and also like the
framework and I jump to the generated
code
so both wide and visual studio you can
do F12 into generated code with both
white and visual studio okay you just
sometimes misbehave but generally it
doesn't work for me so maybe uh I've got
an old version
maybe maybe yeah it may be Visual Studio
yeah